so I tried to schedule it earlier but
they had a cancellation so her didn't
take that and I will you see my doctor
for like a week okay I understand I'm
just wondering how many of these
appointments they're gonna be okay for
stress out of a class maybe consider
dropping something and taking a lighter
course load it's not about being
stressed out in class okay you tried
yoga doesn't work maybe you should try
smoking weight you know that just makes
me more anxious Barbara I'm sorry I miss
Tara but we need your doctor to
authorize a refill yes what Barbara you
know that I need my prescription bra
Babs come on we go back I'm here every
30 days sometimes sooner if I have a
yeast infection I have anxiety okay I
have anxiety today I had anxiety
yesterday they have no reason to believe
that I won't have anxiety tomorrow if
you get your doctor to call right though
can you not just help me out on like
principal didn't you take an oath okay
um can I come in today at lunch
actually I'm not a pills though I did
actually but I had to cancel it because
I had a geology exam in with geology you
have to be there in person because sure
so it's working well yep
any new side effects it's just that last
week was a really tough week for me and
if you'd like I can put you on another
drug that some others have had success
with it's an anti-seizure drug I don't
have seizures
yes but another effect of that I still
need to come back in two months actually
I'd like to see you in one month if we
put you on this yeah hi I'm calling to
check up on a refill for Dara lastname
firstname Kelsey for the K 1990 4045 you
said 45 30 minutes ago
it'll be 15 minutes
darah that'll be a $600 copay what I'm
sorry did you want the generic obviously
burtraw okay that'll be 45 minutes